[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
bible the word of god
welcome to bible answers live providing
accurate and practical answers to all
your bible questions
our phone lines are open if you have a
bible related question give us a call
now at 800 god says that's
facts 800-463-7297
pastor doug batchelor
hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact
dragonflies are among the fastest of all
insects having been clocked at over 60
miles an hour fossils tell us that
before the flood some dragonflies had a
wingspan of nearly three feet
not only are they fast but they're
strong too
about half of their body mass is devoted
to flight muscles and they have the
ability to lift more than twice their
body weight a feat that no man-made
aircraft has ever come near
they can take off backwards then
accelerate at warp speed then stop in an
instant they can also execute an
unbanked turn as if on a pivot
somersault in the heat of combat and fly
virtually any maneuver using an infinite
combination of its four wings
not only can the dragonfly outmaneuver
anything else on wings you can see
better too
its wraparound compound eyes contain
over thirty thousand lenses providing a
360 degree field of view
in fact a dragonfly can see a gnat three
feet away
dart from its nest seize and devour the
prey and return to its perch all in
about one second
in addition the success rate when
hunting is nearly a hundred percent
where compared to like a peregrine
falcon or a lion it's 25 percent
the u.s air force has studied the
amazing flight versatility of
dragonflies and wind tunnels hoping to
uncover the secret of their incredible
aerodynamic abilities
yet
the extraordinary flying ability and
seeing ability of dragonflies doesn't
match up with some characters in the
bible
pastor ross
well i know where you're going with that
pastor doug talking about speed i mean
dragonflies are fast but in comparison
to other created beings they don't even
come close we're talking about angels
yeah angels the bible says also has
wings we have a description of angels
with wings in the bible but these
amazing
creations these amazing beings the bible
calls them ministering spirits
can travel faster than the speed of
light so we're thinking probably the
speed of thought you'd think there's
something between
the speed of light and how fast angels
go we don't know what that measurement
is but there's an example in the bible i
believe in the book of daniel
yeah there's an interesting passage
you're finding daniel chapter 9
a little bit of the background here you
have the prophet daniel who's praying
for understanding
and in response to his prayer the angel
gabriel is sent to answer daniel's
prayer and we actually find the verse
here in daniel chapter 9 starting in
verse 21 it says yes while i was
speaking in prayer this is daniel the
prophet the man gabriel whom i had seen
in the vision at the beginning being
caused to fly swiftly reached me about
the time of the evening offering so
passed today here we have
here we have daniel i should say the
prophet praying for understanding
and then the angel gabriel gets the
commission go answer daniel's request we
find in verse 23 of the same chapter
that says now gabriel is speaking and he
says at the beginning of your
supplication that's the beginning of his
prayer the commandment went out and i've
come to tell you for you are greatly
beloved therefore consider the matter
and understand the vision
so
you look back a little further in the
chapter you probably got 10 minutes of
talking or maybe even less where daniel
is praying he begins his prayer
confessing his sins
from that point to where gabriel
suddenly appears in front of daniel he
flies from heaven to earth in a very
short period of time yeah it's just
fractions of seconds or minutes going
all that distance which is encouraging
to know when you're in trouble
and you pray it doesn't take very long
for the
paramedic to get to you the heavenly
paramedic and what do they call the 911
response time it's pretty quick for
heaven
well pastor rossi it's good to be here
for the program tonight i want to
welcome you friends if you've got bible
questions we're going to launch off
that's what this program is all about
and you can either watch
on
3abn or i'm sorry not three avian yet
we're we're going on there soon we're
going to be on af tv
good news network
and um
facebook
amazing facts
and that's the amazing facts facebook
page doug batchelor facebook page
and we invite you to call in with your
questions if you have a question number
is 800-463-7297
we also have another phone number we
want to tell you about their number is
four 800-835-6747 we'll be repeating
this throughout the program that is our
free resource phone line again that's
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven pass today we're talking
about angels to begin the program we
have an amazing fact study guide that
talks about a special angel born message
that comes from heaven to the earth and
that study guide is called angel
messages from space that's right talking
about the three angels messages that we
find in revelation chapter 14. we'll be
happy to send this study guide to anyone
who calls an ass all you need to do is
call 800-835-6747
and you can ask for the free offer you
can ask for offer number 137 or ask by
name
angel messages from space and we'll be
happy to send that to anyone who calls
and asks if you're outside of north
america please take a look at the
amazing facts facebook page and you'll
be able to read that actually the
website i should say you'll be able to
read the study guide right there yes
before we go to the phone lines we
always like to begin with prayer so
let's do that right now
dear father we thank you that we have
this time once again we can just gather
together through media open up your word
and study
father we thank you for those who are
listening and we pray your blessing upon
this program guide us into a clearer
understanding what the bible teaches and
we ask this in jesus name amen amen
well we really go to the phone lines you
know before we do that pastor we should
just mention i think some of our folks
who tune in regularly every week they
realize that we've been gone for two
weeks
we just finished up a series that we did
in las vegas called inspiration the
bible's greatest stories i believe that
full 10 part series is still available
at the amazing facts youtube page or
youtube channel and if you have not seen
that friends we encourage you to take a
look at that it was just such a joy to
be able to share these bible truths and
pastor one of my favorite topics uh as
you know is where you take bible stories
and you bring out different practical
lessons and that was just such a
blessing so friends if you haven't yet
seen it please make sure that you look
at inspiration the bible's greatest
stories all right ready to go to the
phone lines we've got april listening in
florida april welcome to the program
hi good evening pastor doug good evening
pastor john it's good to hear you guys
again thank you for calling
thank you for accepting my call um
inspiration was awesome in las vegas and
um cover to cover part 7 was awesome too
so my question is
thank you so my question is in the book
of john
jesus mentioned
nobody has seen the face of god or
i think he said nobody's seen the face
of god
but i believe
abraham moses and elijah
are in heaven
also
when jesus was on the mountain and i'm
sorry i don't have my bible with me um
when jesus was on the mountain i believe
with abraham and elijah
james peter and john i believe saw them
so why would jesus say i think to the
pharisees
nobody has seen the face of god except
for the son of man
yeah i think that the key there is jesus
actually says no man have seen the
father
and so people have seen jesus the son
now
if you look exactly for an example if
you go to exodus chapter 33 moses says
lord show me your glory and he said no
man can see my
glory matter of fact let me see if you
look in verse 20
he said you cannot see my face no man
can see my face and live
and so to see the face of god in his
undiminished glory
i would just be too much now that's
because we're in our sinful condition
so once moses and elijah are in heaven
and they've got their glorified bodies
they can endure the presence of god
indeed adam and eve used to walk with
god in the garden so they could see god
and they were probably you know spending
time with god the son
in those encounters
but
god the father in particular in his
undiminished glory
uh humans especially in our lost
condition we could not bear the sight it
would consume us be like a laser
so that's there's a distinction there
and often when people have seen god
he's been he's veiled his divinity
in uh in the form of a man or something
and
um
would appear
to people like abraham and jacob
and
manoa or you know manoa and his wife
so would that be christ that appeared in
the old testament to abraham and
yeah those are called christophanies
they're the pre-incarnation appearances
of jesus jesus appeared several times
that's why jesus said to the jewish
leaders you know abraham longed to see
my day and he sought jesus appeared to
abraham
and of course
abraham saw christ in the sacrifice of
when he offered isaac he saw him
prefigured there
so hope that makes sense april that um
it is still true no man can see the face
of god the father but clearly people
have seen god the son
all right next quarter that we have is
palmer listening from um
is that iowa palmer welcome to the
program
i'm glad to be here
i'm glad you guys were willing to take
this uh question sure
the question is um
the
in daniel chapter two the stone
that turns into a mountain and fills the
whole earth
does that is that a literal kingdom
after the millennium
well let's let's use some biblical
hermeneutics here
when we look at daniel 2 and you see
there's in the image their head is of
gold and the
arms are silver and the belly is bronze
and the legs of iron and the feet are
iron and clay
do
those other metals represent real
kingdoms palmer
and
you know obviously babylon really
represented a literal kingdom of babylon
the head of gold
and the silver was a literal kingdom of
persia so when you get down to the stone
to be consistent it must be a literal
kingdom of jesus
and not only did christ you know begin
preaching the spiritual kingdom when he
came 2000 years ago we're looking
forward to a literal kingdom
uh the spiritual kingdom has always been
available it's within you
but the literal kingdom is still future
because you know the devil is contesting
this world
and but jesus is going to you know
create a new heavens and new earth and
it says the knowledge of god will fill
the world that's when that new kingdom
is established on earth
you know pastor there's an interesting
verse that i like in matthew 21 verse 44
and palmer maybe you've never seen this
verse before it's actually jesus and he
says whoever falls upon this stone shall
be broken
but on whomever it falls it will grind
him to powder
it's kind of interesting christ here is
referring to daniel chapter 2 because
the stone that comes and strikes the
image upon its feet it says it grinds
all of these various metals to powder
and the wind blows it away and then the
stone grows and becomes a great mountain
so to fall upon the stone the storm
being christ our hearts are broken but
there is a warning if we don't take
advantage of the salvation that jesus
wants to give us
when the second coming occurs we're
going to be turning to the rocks and the
mountains and say fall on us and hide us
from the face of him or sits upon the
throne so yes it's a very literal
kingdom that'll be established now
there's phases of their kingdom you have
the second coming of christ where the
righteous are taken to him for a
thousand years the wicked are destroyed
but then at the end of the thousand
years you have the great white throne
judgment and the wicked are destroyed
and then the earth is recreated the new
happens the new earth yes
all right well thanks for your call
palmer we got michael also from michigan
michael welcome to the program
yes hello pastor doug pastor ross thanks
for taking my question yeah
my question is if uh
daniel 9 24-27
is
a repeat and enlargement of the kingdom
of grace
where can we find that in daniel 2
and you say daniel 9 well it's talking
about daniel 9 chapter 24-27 is
really that's the prophecy of christ's
first coming
from the time that he would be
anointed with the holy spirit at his
baptism
that's at the end of the 483
days or years
to his crucifixion in the midst of that
final week when he causes the sacrifice
to cease
and so
you know that's the kingdom of grace
when you're in daniel chapter two it's
talking about god's a literal kingdom so
they're they're covering uh different
time periods so i'm not sure
did we say something about the kingdom
of grace and daniel 2 that you're
looking for
well
if
daniel 9 24-27 is a repeat and
enlargement
of the kingdom of grace i'm wondering
where it is in daniel 2.
well
when
when jesus comes
it's you know
let me say this differently the kingdom
of grace actually is available from
creation
what that lamb that was slain from the
foundation of the world everybody saved
old testament new testament is saved by
grace
so all through daniel 2
god's people are always spared through
grace
nobody's saved by law
well i think you you do find an
interesting feature when you look at
daniel chapter 2 and daniel chapter 7
and you get daniel chapter 8 and then
daniel chapter 9.
it does cover
much of the same time period but each of
the various visions amplify and give
additional details so daniel chapter 2
is focused primarily on
powers political powers and ultimately
the kingdom of god being established on
earth and then you finally daniel 9 the
emphasis there is on
the spiritual kingdom the establishment
of that kingdom that jesus preached when
he came and he said the kingdom of
heaven is at hand that's the kingdom of
grace so daniel is addressing both the
kingdom of glory as well as the kingdom
of grace in the various visions in
daniel 2 daniel 7. you also have the
judgment that's referred in daniel 7 and
you also find that referred to in daniel
8. so there's a number of parallels
between these visions
yeah
so hope that helps a little bit michael
and we appreciate yeah that you can see
the grace all the way through all the
prophecies
but uh yeah they continue to expand not
only in daniel in revelation
they continue to enlarge all right i
think we're ready for marcus marcus
welcome listening on listening from
tennessee marcus welcome to the program
oh hi um
um my question is what is the image to
the beast
all right very good
when you read in revelation chapter 13
it talks about that these there's two
beasts in revelation 13 you got this
first beast
and
it comes up out of the sea and then you
get the second beast that comes up out
of the land
and he encourages the world to make an
image the first beast who had a wound by
the sword a deadly wounded but yet he's
revived
he still lived
and
the first beast
was the persecuting power
of the dark ages from like 538 to about
1798 that was 1260 years
when the papal power
was persecuting
like 50 million
uh christians died during that time and
jews and you get the huguenots and the
walden seas and and many others
um and this is not you know something
original with our radio program this is
what the protestants taught like luther
wesley
spurgeon i mean you can go down the line
all the
puritans and the protestants believe
that so that would be the first beast
but then you've got this other beast
which we believe is the united states
which has you know it's kind of been the
beach head for protestants but there's
going to be apostasy which we already
see in the church
and they're going to encourage the world
to make an image that means a likeness
they're going to do a recreate a
religious political system
that is very similar
and that is going to be once again a
persecuting power if you do not worship
the way you're told that's what it says
if you do not worship the image of the
beast you can't buy or sell and you'll
ultimately be killed
and
i don't think those days are very far
away
i always think it's interesting you know
if you look at a picture of the vatican
and then you look at a picture of the
capitol building
they look like they're copied after each
other and you look in front of the
vatican they've created a great obelisk
is there and in front of the capitol
you've got the washington monument
and so it's it's kind of interesting
they're both kind of based on this
greco-roman architecture but that's not
the image it's not the architecture it's
the
the power of the government that it's
going to be a persecuting power yeah
yeah i think pastor you mentioned it a
little earlier during the dark ages he
had a religious power the church that
was using the state the political power
to enforce worship or a certain type of
worship so an image to the beast would
be when religious powers in the united
states
put emphasis or
motivate
coerce
the government
to start forcing a certain type of
worship or religion
that would be an image to the first
beast that's like a facsimile is making
an image of something and the second
beast encourages the world it's like a
facsimile of the first beast right right
we think image we think idol it's not
like the world's going to be told to
worship a big buddha
it's talking about it'll be a similar
system and then it's not only the united
states but with the support of the
united states it spreads around the
world right it's global you know we have
a study guide it's called the united
states in bible prophecy just the u.s in
bible prophecy and we'll be happy to
send this to anyone who wants to learn
more about this this is such an
important and fascinating study if you'd
like to receive that the number to call
is
800-835-6747 you can ask for the study
guide it's called the usa in bible
prophecy i'll be able to send it to
anyone who calls and asks
we've got fred listening from
connecticut fred welcome to the program
uh yes um
should a christian uh be playing the
stock market
all right good question
well when you say playing the stock
market i think a christian ought to
avoid anything that
borders on gambling
now investing in the stock market is
it's not nothing wrong with that morally
because if you put your money in the
bank
what banks do is they invest in the
market banks don't just sit on the money
or they lend it out and
and they try and gain interest and
when you
invest in the stock market you're
basically buying part ownership of
companies
now as a christian i would not recommend
you buy part ownership of
rjr reynolds what is it tobacco
you might not want to buy part ownership
in anheuser-busch
which makes budweiser and you know
those are not things that christians
should
support but there are you know
legitimate companies that you know maybe
a construction company or whatever
and they're doing well and you'd like to
invest in it there's nothing wrong with
that when people start doing a lot of
day trading it's almost like they're
doing speculation and that can kind of
border on gambling can be very dangerous
but
there's nothing morally wrong with
investing money in the stock market and
i think there are companies that
specialize in
certain companies that that have a good
reputation they are not involved in
tobacco alcohol or certain forms of
entertainment and
a christian can uh
work with those different investment
companies and know that your funds are
going to a good cause yeah and when you
buy a mutual fund
a mutual fund is a company that has a
bouquet of stocks they've bought
that are either conservative or they're
aggressive or they're overseas or
whatever and
and um
you know jesus said in that parable of
the ten talents he condemns the lazy
servant who hides his money he buries it
says you could have at least given it to
the bankers that i'd get interest
and so typically over time the stock
market increases there's an occasional
crash but
it usually goes up all right thank you
for your call fred we've got anthony
listening in new york anthony welcome to
the program
hello good evening pastors um
i have a pretty serious question um
i want to know how do we
know if someone
is struggling with demon possession
demonic possession
and
if if so uh what do we do or what can we
do to help if anything
well let's assume that you know it's
demonic depression we'll answer the
second part of the question first what
can you do to help
in the bible there's no question that
jesus said that you know you will have
power you can pray and you can cast out
devils
and
the disciples came to jesus once and
said we tried to cast this devil out of
this man's son and we couldn't he said
well this kind only comes forth by
prayer and fasting
so through prayer sometimes if it's
especially serious you'd pray and fast
in the bible sometimes it's you know
claiming the name of jesus paul did it
that way when the girl was following him
in philippi
sometimes they laid hands on somebody or
touched them
but so
christians should pray for others if
they're grappling with demonic
possession
i've done a lot of work overseas and
it's more prevalent pastor ross was born
in africa it's more prevalent in some of
these countries there's a lot of where
there's a lot of spiritualism
and
i've had people just
go berserk during my meeting the pastors
grabbed the person man or woman and they
prayed over them and you'd see their
sanity return
so there's that now how do you know if
it's demonic possession
well that's a that's a more difficult
question uh you know there are some
people they've just got a plain old
medical problem that's affecting their
behavior
and
you know and
a doctor can sometimes help you identify
something like that
there's a thin line sometimes between
what may be purely demonic and spiritual
and what might be
physiological
and i think the devil can even combine
the two
meaning a person might have a propensity
to behave erratically and the devil will
take advantage of the the chemical or
biological problem
and with a spiritual
push pushes them over the edge
so
that is difficult sometimes it's hard to
tell i've noticed that some people that
when it's uh
satanic or spiritual it's like they they
become preoccupied with spiritual things
even the devils
the demons possess devils they would say
they call jesus out we know who you are
jesus son of the most high god they
became obsessed with spiritual things
and of course i think the devil is very
good in masquerading
his his influence over people in in
western societies it might not be that
prevalent because people aren't
worshiping the spirits as you might find
in some other places but the devil's
hold over the hearts and the minds of
people in western countries are just as
strong and stronger than some of these
other places materialism and that's
pride yeah absolutely you know i have a
book that i wrote anthony and it's
called broken chains and it talks about
when jesus cast a devil or a legion of
devils out of a man that was desperately
possessed
now that's not among the free books it's
a little it's a little bigger book and
but you can get that
by just going to the amazing facts
website it's called broken chains
all right thanks nicole we got eric and
he's listening in indiana eric welcome
to the program
hello there's a strong pattern in the
old testament of all the kings being
judged into our lives according to doing
what is right in the sight of the lord
or what is evil in the sight of the lord
and certain terms such as high places or
groves
or sacred poles or ashering poles are
used
and when we compare the revelation the
symbols of jezebel being defined as one
who teaches sexual immorality or babylon
spreading it throughout the whole world
or the name written in the forehead of
the woman being prostitute how strong of
a case can we make that god was
referring to prostitution in these kings
judgments and how seriously does god
take uh prostitution and judge societies
by the level in it
well prostitution they call it the
oldest profession is very clearly
condemned in the bible
and
it is also true that in many of the
ancient
religions in these cult religions
even in just the last 70 years they
still had it in india where some of the
hindu temples had what they call temple
virgins but they didn't stay that way
long
and it was a terrible way of abusing
young girls
but
a lot of the ancient idolatry involved
um
sexual promiscuity
and they they called about sacrifices on
the high places to the ash ashram
not so much with baal worship as with
some of the others but
god typically calls idolatry harlotry in
the bible
and
because babylon
is there's so much idolatry in
revelation 17 that that woman
she's called the harlot
so whenever god's people went to worship
idols god called it infidelity or
harlotry
so there's an overlap between the two
you can't always say that every time
people worshipped idols that there was
you know prostitution uh were or
you know they had the temple prostitutes
or whatever not every religion had that
but every time they got one after idols
god called it harlotry
so i don't know that's kind of a vague
distinction but i hope that made sense
eric
and thank you for your question looks
like we're running into our mid-time
break don't go away friends we're coming
back we're gonna do more bible questions
and don't forget you can look at the
series that was just produced it's
called greateststories.org
[Music]
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
doug batchelor was the teenage son of a
millionaire father and show business
mother yet he was living in a cave he
had everything money could buy
everything but happiness but all of the
fun and excitement he enjoyed left his
life out of control
his search eventually led him to a cave
above palm springs that became his home
while doug scavenged for food and
garbage bins his father owned a yacht a
learjet and an airline
but in his cave home he discovered a
dust-covered bible
as he began to read he soon learned of
his true purpose in life
the richest caveman is the extraordinary
true story of doug batchelor that tells
how a rebellious teenager who once lived
in a cave became a tremendous soul
winner for jesus christ it's a thrilling
testimony of the transforming power of
god's word to order your copy of the
richest caveman call 800-538-7275
or visit afbookstore.com
in six days god created the heavens and
the earth
for thousands of years man has
worshipped god on the seventh day of the
week
now each week millions of people worship
on the first day
what happened
why did god create a day of rest
does it really matter what day we
worship
who is behind this great shift discover
the truth behind god's law and how it
was changed visit sabbathtruth.com
would you like to know god's plan for
our troubled world and solutions for
your life's challenges beautifully
redesigned and updated amazing facts 27
bible study guides provide
straightforward bible-based answers that
are enlightening encouraging and easy to
understand giving you real relevant
bible answers to questions like how can
i have healthier relationships when will
jesus come and much more order yours
today by visiting afbookstore.com
or by calling
[Music]
answered 800-538-7275 a clearer picture
of god and his plan to save you so what
are you waiting for get practical
answers about the good book for a better
life today
[Music]
if you have a question about the bible
or living the christian life call us now
at 800 god says that's 800-463-7297
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live
hi listening friends if you have joined
us along the way this is bible answers
live and we're here to do our best to
answer your bible questions and if you
want to call in with a question it's 800
god says that's 800-463-7297
and we're not going to terry long we're
going to go back to the phones my name
is doug batchelor my name is john ross
and we have uh darius listening on the
phone from oklahoma darius welcome to
the program
hey pastas goodnight can you hear me we
can
okay hey um this is my question
so i wanted to know
if i should go back to my church because
my pastor told me
something that i know that contrary to
the bible
he says that
it's okay to go to a football game on
the sabbath and he said that i am too
black and white for the bible
so i'm just i know it's discouraged and
i don't know i don't know what to do i
don't want to go about that i'm looking
for a new church so can you give me some
points on that
yeah all right so the question is if
you're
if you're in a church and um
you know the pastor is telling you
something that he believes categorically
untrue
well that often will cast the other
teachings uh under a light of suspicion
you wonder what else is he saying that i
may not be aware of that is not biblical
and so it is cause for concern i would
not say that uh you know if people in
our church pastor ross and i both
pastored the same church
if they said if i ever hear pastor doug
say anything wrong i'm not coming back
there'd be nobody left
because i'm sure i've said things wrong
because we're humans and the bible says
uh what in the abundance of words sin is
not lacking
uh sometimes you just misspeak so if
someone said you know as soon as he says
something wrong or he mispronounces
something i'm not coming back
but then there's the other
extreme where
if you sit under
erroneous teachings
that can affect your perspective and you
see in ancient israel that whenever the
king was not dedicated to god
gradually the whole nation seemed to
slip away because it followed the
leadership
so you know that's something you have to
pray about i don't know
i i i would be surprised if uh if a
pastor tells people there's nothing
wrong with going to a football game
on the sabbath day
uh it's
you know it's that's holy time for
worshiping god and
the environment of a football game with
people you know kind of calling out for
the uh
the defeat of their enemy and your
opponent just is not the right
mind and attitude and place for worship
so that would really really surprise me
but
nothing i guess really surprises me
anymore
so in that case pathetic we're just
suggesting is you know if it's if we're
in a church that is
clearly not preaching the bible or
advocating teaching teachings that are
not biblical
you know we've said something we've
spoken to the leadership at some point i
think we want to find
ourselves with those who are following
the bible as closely as they can yeah so
that might mean looking for another
church and you brought up a very good
point that i just want to expand a
little bit is if you've got a pastor and
he says something that is just out of
left field and surprises you
respect him enough to go to him and even
for his own soul approach him and say
you know according to the bible that is
not right and then a loving spirit and
humility
you know it might bring them to
conviction and turn them around and so
make at least an effort to
be reconciled with your brother so to
speak and and try and draw them back but
if they're firm and preaching error that
it's probably not healthy to continue
going
okay we've got steve listening in
california steve welcome to the program
hi pastor thanks for taking my call sure
um
my question is when
cain was banished
um
he went to the land of mod who lived in
the land of mod
well in the very beginning
the land was talking about an area a
region that was later named it's just
telling you where he went you know
there's no people there yet
and so when cain left he went to a part
of this virgin world country
and developed it it was later named
according to what the various patriarchs
named it but when they first went
it had no name because there were no
aborigines or other people living there
so i think moses is just just telling us
what where that region
is
now and um
there's more than one place called nob
actually in the bible david
there's a place not far from the
philistines called nob too but that's
not the one that cain went to and of
course a lot of things changed this of
course happened before the flood and so
many years passed and then you had the
flood and then you had the writing of
the bible during the time of moses
so
it's referring to a place that was
fairly well known to people at the time
when
genesis was written by moses yep all
right thanks you're cool steve we've got
daniel in canada daniel welcome to the
program
hi um pastors um this is daniel here so
god
i mean if satan tempted adam and eve in
the garden of eden and our hearts became
hard
just like god said our hearts are evil
like why did god allow our hearts to
become evil in the first place why must
we suffer for the sins of adam and eve
yeah and you could even expand that
question and say
you know why are some children born with
birth defects because of the bad living
habits of their parents you know some
kids are born with cerebral palsy
because the parents had alcohol problems
and why are people in ukraine suffering
because
you've got you know an individual that's
bombing them what did they do
sin
well first of all let me back up and go
to the very heart of it
god made his intelligent creatures free
with a free will to choose to love him
or choose not to love him
and as soon as man chose to
distrust god and not to love god
his compass needle inside was broken
what i mean by that is we're normally
created
to love god first the great commandment
is love the lord with all your heart
even more than yourself and then love
your neighbor as you love yourself
and when man fell into sin
all of a sudden adam and eve are blaming
each other they're not getting along and
they're blaming god they're blaming the
devil and the serpent and
and all of a sudden
man's hearts became hard because of sin
god didn't just say i'm going to harden
our hearts
it was what happened because of sin but
making man free to love
means he's free to not love
otherwise god is forcing them to love
and that's not love
and of course freedom does have
consequences
and we need that i mean if you have
freedom to choose to love and to be a
blessing and to be an encouragement to
somebody
well then you also have freedom to
hurt and discourage
others and people make their choices so
the choices that we make
does have an impact upon those around us
absolutely and of course the devil's
choices made an impact upon adam and eve
and of course all of their descendants
all right thank you daniel we've got
caleb listening in new york
hello pastor ross and pastor that's what
how you doing
really good thank you for calling
i'm good thank you well by the way i
have a question i'm reading the bible
right now
and um i want to know
two questions which version is better to
me right now i'm reading the niv version
which is easier for me to understand
than
the king james version i want to know if
that's okay and
two i read the gospels before and not
until i started watching your sermon
i started understanding more things i've
missed clearly like i've missed i was
wondering like is there a way like is
that pattern i shouldn't read the bible
to get more understanding
yeah well let's
good questions very first part of the
question and you know pastor ross might
answer slightly different than i would i
think there's several good translations
of the bible you can read that are
there uh their translations from what
they call the texas receptus which is i
think the most accurate and that would
be of course king james is the classic
in english and when we say translations
we're talking about english translations
um right now i'm reading through the
english standard version which is also a
translation from the texas receptus that
is a good the american standard version
the new king james version is what i
usually preach from every week is the
new king james version
um i don't know pastor ross you have
some other favorite
yeah you know maybe just to add to that
there's a difference that we need to
understand between a translation and a
paraphrase now we're just talking about
english right so a translation is is
where you take the original greek and
hebrew a little bit of aramaic and you
translate that into english but a
paraphrase might be where you know you
could do this i could do this we take an
english translation and we rewrite it in
other words and we bring out different
ideas it's more devotional i'm not
saying all paraphrases are wrong but if
we're going to study to find doctrinal
you know depth we want to go with a good
translation and
we also got to remember the bible wasn't
written originally in english it was
written in greek and hebrew and that's
where having a concordance and being
able to compare scripture with scripture
and go back and look at some of the
original ways the words were used is
always helpful and that really enlarges
a person's study of the bible yeah and
let the bible interpret itself if you
see a word
and you think i wonder what that word
means look at other places in the bible
where that term or that word is used and
usually through context of it you can
say oh now i see what they're saying
so
that just happened to me this week when
we were studying about moses and it said
that rock that followed them was christ
and i was picturing this boulder rolling
around through the wilderness and kept
giving him water and then i looked up
where it says rock and i said no no
moses is talking about god
he calls god the rock many times in
deuteronomy so
uh just by comparing it with other
places is usually one of the best ways
and how do we study the bible well again
pastor ross might be a little different
than me but
i'm always reading through the bible at
different points i think you're trying
to read through the whole bible in how
long yeah well there's different
programs you can do you can actually
read through the bible in 90 days it's
about an hour of reading every day yeah
didn't realize you can actually get
through it that quickly so yeah i try to
read through the bible at least once or
twice a year
and then there's some great commentaries
as well that you can read alongside that
that really helps to to bring it to
light there's different ways of reading
pastor you can just read it to get the
big picture which you know if you're
going to read through the bible in a
year you're doing a lot of reading and
you're getting the big picture which is
good but there's also where you you
focus more on a shorter passage of
scripture and really try to squeeze out
everything that that chapter or that
passage has to say and that's what takes
a little more time that's where you
compare scripture with scripture and
both is good
absolutely
yeah i read i use the computer program i
use logos and also use a free one called
east sword and i find between the two of
them i get some great commentaries and
some great tools
so that's probably more than
that get you started
yeah you can read through the bible you
can start with the new testament read
the history meaning you go from genesis
through the kings and then jump to the
new testament
thanks so much caleb hope that helps a
little we've got robert listening from
new jersey robert welcome to the program
good evening pastor pastor doug and
pastor russ good evening uh my question
my question is just concerning um
did it rain prior to the flood or not is
there evidence from the bible on either
and i'll take my answer off to you
all right yeah thank you very much
i believe that the bible is pretty clear
that prior to the flood it had not
rained
and um
you can reverse pastor i know where
you're going with it
genesis i just found on the computer
genesis chapter 2
and verse 6 it says speaking of before
the flood
are actually verse 5 it says before any
plant at the field was in the earth and
before any herb of the field had grown
for the lord god had not caused it to
rain on the earth and there was no man
to till the ground but a mist went up
from the earth and watered the whole
face of the ground
yeah
so
it appears and not only from what you
read in the bible but just from the
fossil record
that prior to the flood
that there was
an envelope of water vapor or something
that sort of surrounded the whole planet
that polarized the rays and gave an even
temperature around the planet because
even in
what do you call antarctica up in
siberia they find
fossils of ferns
which you know are usually grown in a
tropical climate so the whole
world was changed after the flood and it
didn't rain like it does now i think
there was just moisture and mist that
kind of irrigated
and watered things
all right well thank you richard we've
got uh pat listening in arizona pat
welcome to the program
thank you
thank you pat
your question thank you for taking my
call yeah
how can we help you what's your question
my question is is gambling a sin
i believe so
uh pastor ross and i just came back from
las vegas
but i never saw the inside of a casino
we weren't gambling
we were doing some evangelistic programs
there but you know the the reason well
first of all the bible says make not do
not make haste to be rich and he that
makes haste to be rich will
not be without
guilt
and so the idea of getting rich quick by
playing numbers
first of all um
99.9
of the people that do that lose money
because the whole system is set up where
the house wins
and it's anything that becomes an
addiction christians should avoid there
are people who actually become addicted
to gambling and it destroys their lives
and they can't stop it's like a
psychosis
and i remember doing a meeting in
another country
and the lady came up to me just sobbing
and she says i'm addicted to gambling
and
and you know i've i've mortgaged my home
i've run up our credit cards my
husband's getting ready to leave me and
i can't stop
and even before i got done counseling
with her she says but there's this one
more race
and i think if i win that race i can win
it all back and
i couldn't believe she just she was
thinking about the next bet even as we
talk well you know there's another
aspect of gambling that we need to bear
in mind as a christian is you if you do
get lucky and you do win
you're winning at a lot of other
people's
losing so you winning because about this
misfortune
yeah so you're really taking advantage
of other people that same thing with the
lottery right yeah
so yeah it's and you know it's
interesting you study the history of
people that have won the lottery and
most of them don't do very well if you
look what happens the next couple of
years money disappears some even get
murdered yeah it's not good
all right thanks your call pap we've got
glenn listening in ohio glenn welcome to
the program
good evening
thank you very much for taking my call
hey glenn you're gonna have to get close
to your phone we can barely hear you
you might be on a speaker phone
all right well try it ask your question
we'll do our best to repeat it and then
uh answer it off here
of the scripture second corinthians 5 8
and i think it has doctrinal
implications right there most people say
that paul said to the answers from the
body is to be present with the lord and
that's not what that says that people
misquoted can you help me understand
what the proper understanding is
yeah we'll do our best all right so our
friends if you want to go to second
corinthians 5 8
and this is often quoted when it talks
about people dying
um and paul says and i'll start with
verse uh yeah we'll start with verse
eight yes we are confident yes well
please rather to be absent from the body
and to be present with the lord and then
you need to read on here it says
therefore we make it our aim whether
present or absent to be well pleasing to
him for we must all appear before the
judgment seat of christ that each one of
us might receive the things done in the
body according to what he's done whether
good or bad and so
you know paul
earlier in that passage he says because
i'm
i'm kind of in a uh
a quandary between two things he said on
one hand he says i want to i'd love to
depart and be with the lord
meaning when a christian dies
their next conscious thought is going to
be the resurrection and the presence of
the lord but paul said it's needful for
you that you know i stay here
well it is true that if we die and these
bodies turn back to dust the bible's
very clear
and
for the believer the next conscious
thought it's there's no sensation of
time as to be the presence of the lord
but it doesn't happen until there's a
judgment in the resurrection you know
and it also says paul was a prophet so
he had visions in another place he
actually talks about seeing something in
vision and he says whether i was absent
from the body or in the body i can't
quite remember and then he tells the
story
so you know paul was at times taken off
in vision that would be considered
absent from the body
but i think here it's talking about you
know when we receive our reward it's at
the second coming of christ and we get
these immortal bodies
and um
first verse in chapter five for we know
that if our earthly house this tent is
destroyed yep that's pretty clear i'm
talking about the body when you're dead
right right yeah so thank you richard
thank you
we've got uh uh ivan listening from
mexico
yvonne welcome to the program
hello
hi um
it's an honor to talk to you since
i talked to you first in a long time ago
but
you might not remember me
well thank you for calling it again
yvonne
and by the way
god willing i'll be in mexico if you're
anywhere near mexico city i'm doing
meetings in mexico city next october
so anyway your question by the way
yeah by the way
i'm not that mexican at all i'm spanish
irish and that's my question about it
um ask me
as irish descendant can we celebrate
saint patrick's day my family too is
irish
all right now just question you it says
here on the phone you're calling from
mexico
yeah
i just want to make sure
but so um
there's no scripture that tells us
there's anything sacred about saint
patrick's day
and um i'm sure that if patrick patrick
was a very godly man he was actually a
protestant it's interesting that the
catholics made
patrick
a saint and he was a protestant
and patrick was also a sabbath keeper
some people don't know that he he kept
the seventh-day sabbath
but
nowhere are we told to worship
saints in the bible
and so
you know sometimes for fun in north
america it's a tradition you'll wear a
green tie and people say it's st
patrick's day and so too
just uh to commiserate with our irish
friends and my family's part irish my
brother had flaming red hair
but
you know we'll wear something green on
st patrick's day
but um
yeah it's i wouldn't worship it as far
as a spiritual holiday
so hope that helps a little bit thank
you yvonne appreciate your question
all right we've got anita listening from
maryland anita welcome to the program
hi how are you pastor um
can you hear me we can
okay um i uh today uh march 27th is my
is the third anniversary of my 18 year
old's death
so my question is related to his death
um
aaron he worked at a restaurant where he
we didn't know till he died
that he somebody was giving him medical
marijuana
um
he was acting very aggressive and
violent towards us his personality
totally changed
and it was actually at work one of my
patients
when i he tried to punch me that morning
i went to work and i was telling her you
know how he was behaving she's like oh
your son's on marijuana and she told me
all the symptoms and what to look for so
when i got home
she told me you know it's like drunk
drink like drunk driving she told me
let's you know check his clothes in his
room and yes that's what we found but he
was already at work
i called him at work made a big mistake
not knowing much about marijuana
thinking you know it's a harmless drug
like everyone else i was totally wrong
he actually
after work
after i called him and i yelled at him
instead of coming straight home he used
all the marijuana he had because he knew
mom and dad are going to take everything
away
he had a psychosis
crashed his car into a tree near our
house
survived that crash
walked out onto i-95 and was run over
and killed he was hit the first person
that
hit him the first car was a 28 year old
the history of dui marijuana drunk
driving so my question is
kind of loaded
i feel extremely guilty because i
caused
his death and i
plus aaron wasn't was not baptized
so
i kind of i'm wondering is there a
chance that he could be in heaven and
will i be forgiven for what i did
all right let's start with the second
part of that question first of all
you know our hearts go out to you i know
this is um that's a heartbreaking that's
that's like one of the worst things that
could happen is losing a child
and uh
my wife and i we lost a 21 year old son
years ago
and uh it's just the worst news that a
parents can have so we we empathize with
you
and then
part of this i want to deal with first
of all is you said can i be forgiven
be careful not to blame yourself
uh for this you were doing probably what
any parent would do you were concerned
about your son's health and well-being
and so you know you may not have reacted
the way if you could play it over again
you might do it differently but you
can't beat yourself up forever about
that because you certainly had no
intention of doing them harm you were
worried about them
and
just you know the bible tells us that
time and chance happens to all
is what solomon says so be careful not
to to read too much meaning into it it
was an accident
and so there was a terrible tragic
accident
and then of course you're wondering now
what does this mean is there a chance
that i'll see my son again this is one
of those situations where you've got to
know that god is good god is love and
that god loves your son infinitely more
than you do
and he will do what is good
and so you just put this in god's hands
and trust him
you know we obviously in the program we
can't put ourselves in the position of
the eternal and say we think he will or
won't be saved
you know there's guidelines in the bible
for following him
but i think we're going to be surprised
when we get to heaven that there were
some exceptions we didn't anticipate
and so
just the bible talks about the second
coming of jesus as the blessed hope
and so just hang on to hope
and live for the lord trust that he
forgives you god is good and god is love
anita and if it's okay you know pastor
also i'd like to have a brief prayer
with you because i know that you and
others like you
have
have lost children and your hearts are
breaking
loving lord we just pray that you'll be
with anita and i pray and her family or
husband and and help them to just to
heal from this tragedy that's touched
their lives and i pray through it you've
told us that you can bring good from all
things that happen to us and that there
can be redemption that will come from
this story and so be with him in comfort
and bless we pray in jesus name
amen
appreciate your call anita
pastor ross yes we just want to let our
friends know we got about one minute
past that i don't think we have time to
take one more call but the program is
not over because we are going to say
goodbye to those who are joining us on
satellite radio but for the rest of
those who are listening on af tv and
land-based radio stations we're going to
be coming back with a rapid fire bible
question segment where we're going to
actually try and answer as many of the
bible questions that you have sent in to
the ministry through facebook or through
youtube or if you want you can just send
the question to amazingfacts.org
matter of fact i'm getting the address
right here
bal questions at
amazingfacts.org that's the website if
you have a bible question that you want
to submit to the program and pass today
we'll try to answer as many of these
programs as we can yep yeah sometimes
folks uh they they say i'd like to ask a
question but i'm a little scared about
getting on the air
and you can email your questions to us
and at the tail end of the program
just after we say goodbye to the
satellite listeners we're going to be
going and answering some of those
questions that have come in via email
for the rest of you keep in mind you can
continue to study and worship and
enjoy the blessings and programs of
amazing facts at amazingfacts.org
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
bible even better than before
bible answers live is produced by
amazing facts international a
faith-based ministry located in granite
bay california
hello friends welcome back to our
special bonus bible questions segment
i'll pass today we've got several
questions that have been sent in so
we're going to see how many we can get
through tonight first question that we
have is does it really help to pray for
somebody else's salvation
absolutely now
not after they're gone i mean some
people say well burn a candle and say a
prayer after they're gone the bible says
that it's appointed under man once to
die and after that the judgment but
while there the bible says where there's
life there's hope
and so you pray for their salvation
absolutely
moses interceded for the whole nation
and you've got many cases in the bible
where
even jesus said to peter i have prayed
for you that your faith does not fail
so if jesus prayed for others and if
abraham interceded for lot and moses for
the nation
we should be praying for others as well
okay next question that we have what is
the difference between the moral law and
the ceremonial law
yeah a very good question well when you
say moral law that's usually talking
about the the ten commandments which is
a summary of the law of god
sometimes that's called the decalogue
deca meaning ten that ten commandments
that you would find
in
exodus chapter 20
but when you read in deuteronomy chapter
4 when god gives the 10 commandments he
also tells us and i think it's in verse
13 it says god gave me 10 commandments
which he commanded us to perform and at
that time the lord commanded me
to give you statutes and judgments
so there were a number of laws that
revolved around the sanctuary and its
services in its ceremonies they are
called the ceremonial law sacrificing
lambs circumcision all nailed to the
cross
okay another question that we have how
do i determine the will of god
well you know i wrote a little book
called determining the will of god you
can download for free but i'll give you
a couple of highlights i think i give a
dozen points in the book
uh one is study the word uh there's
guidance in the word there's guidance
through the holy spirit speaking to us
you'll hear a voice guiding you through
your conscience christian counsel look
for providential openings
for the word of god and be willing to be
faithful to wait until you know if it's
a big decision okay last question that
we have here pastor doug
if the jews didn't believe that jesus is
the messiah why did they stop
sacrificing lambs
well they kind of were forced to stop
sacrificing lambs they did right at the
crucifixion when the veil was rent but
then when the temple was destroyed in 70
a.d
that's where they had brought all their
sacrifices and god told moses don't do
it on your own bring it to this place
well friends we really are out of time
now we want to thank you for tuning in
to bible answers live look forward to
studying his word with you again next
week
[Music]
you